give me now to react host of media buzz
right here on fox news howard kurtz and
dick morris former senior advisor to
President Bill Clinton I've been dying
to talk to all of you guys you guys
today about this because when I started
hearing this meme this week oh it's the
cult of Trump they they tried to say he
was dumb he was had dementia remember
that last year they needed to you know
remove him from office like the cabinet
had to be activated and now it's like
well they're all just a bunch of cult
Jim Jones kool-aid drinkers Dick Morris
you've seen the cultish slavish
adulation of both Clinton and Obama is
Trump more about policy or personality
well I think his policy is crucial but I
think the thing about his personality
that that is capturing people is that
he's congruent with what people want we
want a president that gets stuff done
without prevaricated a waffling or with
the wind's blowing and Trump is a
builder he's a developer that's what
they do
he gets it built and when he talks about
Korea or Iran or the economy the critics
all say he can't do it it's impossible
but then he gets it done he implements
it and even after he does they still say
you didn't do it or it'll come apart and
that creates a real sense that apart
from ideology apart from the program
apart from party this guy is somebody to
follow because he gets it done it's the
same concept that inspired Reagan and
even Churchill supporters that we don't
care if he's left or right laborer or
Tory or Democrat or Republican we love
the way he acts the way he gets it done
and the way he expresses our innermost
desires about what the government should
do for us right he's unapologetic and
his desire and his impatience I would
say for change for America for American
workers and that that's just refreshing
and Howie you've been around Washington
for so long it's refreshing to hear
somebody like today and I know the media
were all over and saying oh this is they
had the lye meter or something for it
when he went off to the driveway today
and he spent what did he spend how he
like 45 minutes with it
with you know answering questions just
out of the driveway though I've never
say anything like this that was great
but you just wrote a piece about the
supposed cult phenomenon and the lines
coming from the media all week so tell
us your thoughts about where the real
cult phenomenon is today yeah the media
have a new for letter C word for
Republicans who support President Trump
and you know think about that word it's
become so common now cult we kind of
spooky kind of creepy extremist
overtones of course the people who would
follow such a leader are mindless
delusional whack jobs and you know
there's there's a sense here you show
bob Corker early or never misses a
chance to kick the president the media
just following corker but it took me
about you know 15 seconds on the Google
to find New York Times editorial last
week the cult of Trump Axios in February
the cult of Trump National Journal last
year
Trump's cult overwhelms the GOP now I
get the idea that this is President
Trump's Republican Party and whether out
of loyalty or out of fear and many
Republicans are falling into line but to
call it a cult and nobody even gets
upset about it just shows you the media
minds that they still don't quite grasp
final Trump's appeal now it's it's
unbelievable lievable to me dick that
now a year and a half into this his
numbers are going up mothers are going
down historic low unemployment for
african-americans all the measures that
we've talked about confidence is up a
possible denuclearized Korean Peninsula
this is just wild positive stuff
happening and yet this is the best they
have for the attack on Trump you know
they're waiting for the big deliverance
from Muller but this is it and I just
want to play something cuz I know you're
gonna love this Lindsey Graham today
again not always in agreement with Trump
Lindsey Graham was being criticized for
actually working with Trump let's watch
I like the president I trust him in
terms of trying to do things that that
that are big and matter but if people
say this is like two-faced where is the
Lindsey Graham of standing up to Donald
Trump what do you say when I work with
President Obama and I did on occasion I
was a hero now when I were President
Trump I'm two-faced I know how the games
played so if you don't like me working
with
President Trump to make the world a
better place I don't give you got
Lindsey Graham to swear on TV that's
pretty interesting but they they're
trying everything dick but none of it is
sticking I'm telling you I think they're
I think they're like out of political
ammo here close it out for us well I
think there are two things I think first
people that you Republican the Democrats
bet on impeachment they bet on Russia
gate and that's falling apart and they
have no be plan and secondly on policy
that was so clear were opposed to the
tax cut were opposed to Trump's economy
Trump is horrible
that when he accomplishes something
which he's doing tremendously they can't
share the spotlight they can't share the
credit like Republicans could share
Clinton's credit for welfare reform and
the balanced budget was good for them
all they're fresh out of ideas it's
showing and I think the American people
are noticing it sorry I had to cut you
off there